c'est syndicalistes du Technocentre
Renault à Guyancourt s'apprêtait en
début d'après-midi à rejoindre Paris
pour manifester à l'appel de la CGT à
l'occasion de la Journée européenne de
l'industrie était également présent des
salariés de l'usine Renault Flins et de
Peugeot Poissy la veille lundi le
Conseil général des Yvelines avait
organisé une table ronde entre syndicats
et organisation patronales pour échanger
sur l'avenir de l'industrie dans le
département et faire des propositions
nous sommes porteurs d'une proposition
de la tenue d'assise industrielle au
niveau départemental qui puisse
regrouper tous les acteurs de la filière
la désindustrialisation n'est pas fatale
elle est le résultat de la crise du
système qui vise à une rentabilité
financière toujours plus importante et
nous pensons que il y a des choses à
faire par exemple le crédit bancaire
peut servir au développement industriel
à la recherche l'intérêt c'est
effectivement voir comment le conseil
général peut s'impliquer un peu
là-dedans et voir effectivement comment
on peut structurer les actions
coordonnées aider peut-être faire du
lobbying c'est un peu le message aussi
qui nous a été passé par rapport à la
question effectivement du transport par
rapport à la question du logement sur le
plan légal il existait un outil qui
était la gestion prévisionnelle des
emplois au niveau des territoires et ça
il faut l'utiliser il faut l'utiliser
aussi au niveau département ce dont
j'avais besoin moi c'était pas d'avoir
des dossiers mais c'était cette remontée
du vécu par les par les entreprises par
les les
syndicats de ce que vivaient leur au
quotidien leurs adhérents seul bémol à
cette réunion informelle l'absence des
organisations patronales mais def et
CGPME l'industrie représente 16% de
l'emploi dans les Yvelines avec 80000
postes soit 2% de moins qu'en 2008
premiers acteurs touchés et constructeur
automobile et leur sous-traitants